half the company i feel are couples
maybe less maybe more i don't know but
there's a lot of couples
in php insurance agency a lot yeah and i
think pbd was very intentional with that
he doesn't want young single men
out there or selling insurance or even
youngest single women so speak to that a
little bit what's it like because not
only are you
in the business doing that with your
wife you're managing or directing
marketing all that to couples what have
you seen good bad and ugly with that
what works what doesn't work a major
distraction is taken off the plate when
building a business which is the dating
life
the
person that
you go home to
is that distraction is going because
it's not like you're dealing when you're
leaving the office you're not trying to
find a dating life or
you don't have to worry about
unnecessary extracurricular activities
you go home to your husband you go home
to your wife so there's a lot of
stability
when it comes to that
the uh the most uh um
unpredictable type of personality that's
inside uh our business unit would be the
young single ones and by the way i was
there because i was 23 24 years old when
i first started so i'm i'm speaking to
miso just because i'm married it doesn't
mean i'm any better about the situation
but i've been
you know wondering what goes on in the
office also
if you're young and single you're at the
office and you're around people making
money guess what tends to attract a lot
of hot young people to as well
so next you know you don't look at the
offices in office
you look at the offices they
you know hook up some traffic yeah
exactly and by this one of her or
kind of our code of conduct when you
come to office this is not a meat market
if you if you find somebody here at the
office and they're attractive make sure
you find them on the leader's bulletin
otherwise they're a chump
right i don't care about six-pack i care
about no no
no offense here i'm getting rid of a
six-pack i care about six figures all
right right so you know
can he or she provide can they pull
their weight if not i don't care how
they look on instagram i don't care i
look on social media they're going to be
a drag deal because in my opinion you
guys help me chime in on this one but i
believe in a totality of a relationship
sex is about maybe 10 15 of the
relationship i think there's a lot more
of intimacy with sheena and then there
is sex but when there is sex it's
explosive it's the best sex but when
it's just first in a relationship just
for sex just to have sex just get laid
you got paid it's kind of like it's it's
superficial but uh i think when you when
i think 80 90 well all all the
millionaires in in php all married
plowed married not having a kid but for
the most time he was single all the all
the half million income earners 750 only
one person single he's right here john
mason you're you're you're you're you're
brother in the club yeah exactly with
the mot yeah he's probably the only one
out of our 30 40 50 people making half
million dollars
is that part of the culture or is that
just kind of come with the territory
that couples tend to be more successful
together in that business and i also see
it it comes with the territory yeah i
also see it on cash flow because i look
at the cash flow reports i see couples
boom boom boom boom boom steady cash
flow single people up down up down do
you have any brother sister brother
brother stuff like it's going on because
it's not it's del toros okay exactly
yeah vargas's
uh masons so so but that but then that's
my dynamic too because dean and john you
know they have their you know he has
dean's got fernanda john's you know he's
he's dating so it's kind of like
you know
you gotta you gotta worry about the
personal life and then come together in
the business so you wouldn't say it's
not part of the culture it's
it's not
in terms of it of course it's accepted
but because in a sense
if you get a new if you get a new
employee and they're looking around
they're saying that all right cool
everybody's coupled up and whatnot and
it's like oh i can see that everybody's
coupled and everybody works here so in
the sense they would have that pressure
like all right cool i might need to and
we'd find somebody they might feel that
pressure correct and when they get with
somebody yeah
and
another new employee comes in and get
with somebody now it starts becoming
culture what did you say yeah becoming a
consistent habit
we caution it because we don't want to
marry somebody just for business
purposes right of course you got it you
got to marry them because you want to
spend the rest of your life with them
and you know business and career is only
such a small portion of that but uh i i
wouldn't say it's culture it's
definitely a an obvious factoid with
insider company right but if you're
single i mean palaia was single for what
13 14 years but it could it could be
also great that you guys are great um
examples of what it means to be into a
relationship and people want that and
they crave it and that's what happens
yeah every time i go to a php event i'm
like i gotta get married bro
all the guys making a million dollars
i gotta find a wife like that but except
unfortunately i'm in south beach and i'm
just dealing with the baddies who aren't
exactly the baddies uh
in the business
side of things
[Music]